the good GOP has promised for years to
repeal and replace Obamacare but late
last night that effort officially
collapsed the Republican health care
bill fell apart when senators Mike Lee
of Utah and Jerry Moran of Kansas vowed
to vote against the bill their
opposition surprised the White House and
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
with a total of four GOP senators
promising to vote no the plan could
never get the 50 votes needed to pass
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with the
next move for Republican leaders Nancy
good morning it was a late night for
everybody last night
it sure was and Republican leader Mitch
McConnell has already announced his plan
see it is a Hail Mary pass that puts a
number of his own Republican members in
a tough spot he's asking them to vote on
a straight-up repeal of most of
Obamacare with no replacement it's a
bill that they passed two years ago when
the stakes were a lot lower because they
knew it would never become law it's a
very very hard time they're having with
the Obamacare situation so we're going
to get that done hours after the
president predicted victory his own
party members handed him a defeat Kansas
senator Jerry Moran said we should not
put our stamp of approval on bad policy
Utah's Mike Lee said the party's health
care bill doesn't go far enough in
lowering premiums for middle class
families from Phoenix where he's
recovering from surgery John McCain
urged GOP leaders to change course and
receive input from members of both
parties President Trump proposed just
the opposite tweeting Republicans should
just repeal failing Obamacare now and
work on a new health care plan that's a
tactic leader Mitch McConnell argued
against less than two weeks ago
I think repealing it
but last night with few options left
McConnell's sided with the president
announcing a vote in the coming days on
a bill that will be a repeal of
Obamacare with a two-year delay to
provide for a stable transition period
on this vote the yeas are 50 it's the
same repeal bill the Senate passed back
in 2015 but it was vetoed by President
Obama earlier this year the
Congressional Budget Office analyzed
that repeal bill and found that the
number of uninsured would increase by 18
million Americans just in the first year
by 2026 the number would be 32 million
as for premiums the CBO estimates
individual policies would go up 20 to 25
percent in the first year Republican
leaders argue that those numbers would
improve in the out years after they pass
an Obamacare replacement plan but
critics on the left and the right argue
that if the party hasn't been able to
find consensus in the past seven months
who's to say that they'll be able to do
it in the next two years
bianna can see on to Plan C thank you